all right Alan is with us in Austin
Texas hi Alan how are you I'm doing well
Dave and yourself better than I deserve
how can I help perfect my call is
probably about ten years not soon enough
I've got your favorite product the non
term insurance Oh life I guess they
permanent whole life yes and trying to
figure out how to get out of it without
losing my whole shirt too late I was
afraid you were gonna say that you're
just gonna lose your shirt and your
t-shirt if you stay in it so go ahead
and get out get out and pull the
band-aid off huh yeah you're not gonna
it's not gonna get better it's only
gonna get worse and so what am i if I
pull this money out tax wise it'll just
hit on the growth correct on the growth
above everything you put in which 90%
90% of whole life policies do not have
growth above what you put in ok they
suck that bad you don't even get out
what you put in so how much is your
premium about a thousand a month oh my
lord that's what I put in for how long
it's been for 10 so you put 120 thousand
bucks in there
correct and what's the cash value I
surrender value that they're gonna send
you a check for I don't have that in
front of me right the second I do not
know is it in excess of one hundred and
twenty thousand yes yes okay then you'll
be taxed on the amount in excess of that
that is your basis okay your basis is
the total of your premiums paid in yes
and I don't even like thinking about it
and that's why once you know if there is
an easier way out of this but it was not
you know if you back it out and you
figure out what you actually do get out
of it above a hundred and twenty
thousand the national average is 1.2
percent over 10 years so ten percent
give or take I'm gonna guess and say you
probably don't have a hundred and
thirty-five coming out okay but I might
be wrong you have to do my homework
luckily we
debt-free other than we've actually got
our house paid off so we are debt-free
that's great well you just take this
money and invest it wisely and you'll be
right you know you'll make a lot more on
it and they don't keep it when you die
you know if you got the money invested
in mutual funds or something they don't
keep it when you die when it's invested
in whole life policy you die they keep
your money all right and I've asked that
I've asked my agent that and he says no
we give you everything plus what's over
so I know I don't give you the cash
value plus the face value they give you
the face value that's it period huh
that's it and that that's just not
correct now yeah well yeah we give you
the 120 plus we'll give you up to the
face value above 120 yeah that they'll
do but the total is still equals what
the face value which still means what
your hundred twenty thousand that you
paid extra to create is gone you bought
insurance and an investment and you're
only going to get the insurance when you
die that's the problem
so yeah you need to get out of that crap
as fast as you can if you need term life
insurance make sure you have that in
place before you cancel any existing
policies that's the proper thing to do
but man get that done yesterday this has
gone on way long enough